head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard charts here
we are uh this is this is the news and
um Senate staffer caught filming gay sex
tape in Senate hearing room graphic the
image is
blurred heavily thank God
but it's not blurred all over the whole
image not just the whole image is
blurred not just the not quite blurred
enough so uh they know who this guy is
now his name is flying all over the
place there's that wasn't everything
flying all over the place dude the daily
The Daily Caller posted the video of it
like it's it's everywhere Sly on social
media this this guy needs to get like I
don't know man 20 years like like you
know we talking about they want to lock
up Enrique tario he wasn't even in DC on
January 6 and I'm like this is a guy who
probably broke so many laws he's got to
get locked up it's not just him it's
it's two guys and they're enjoying each
other's company quite a great deal if
you know what I'm saying I'm filming it
in the Senate hearing room I'm not like
bullish on law on lawfare and warfare
through law but like at some point you
got to make a precedent don't do this
kind of thing on the Senate hearing
floor I just guys when I said 2024 was
going to be crazy I did not see this one
coming I I thought it was going to be
like a journalist gets woken up at 6:00
in the morning and they like not see
this one coming you're just asking you
just got puns left and right tonight man
did they set up a camera and then like
go get in the middle of the room and get
on some like one of the guys I guess has
uh see you know he everybody's getting
mad at me cuz I'm on X and I'm like is
the guy you're naming the dude being
filmed or the dude doing the deed T Tim
really cares about the details here I
just want to point that out here I do
care I do care so I did watch the video
I AB slow motion rewind trying to figure
out back and for and and you know not
that that much Luke you know you can
calm down I don't know what you were
watching but uh listen I've seen videos
of people brutally murdered I have
watched people die in front of me and
well that's probably hyperbolic I've
watched people die a great distance away
from me from a height I don't want to
make it seem like I was standing in
front of a guy who died I've been shot
at so when this news breaks that a
Democrat staffer there's two guys and
they're going at it and then I see a
bunch of people saying this is the guy
I'm like hold
on is is they said this guy filmed
himself doing this thing and I'm like
how do you know that's actually him it
was an older guy too right no no it's a
young guy it was a younger guy young guy
so here's here's the issue so I so I
half jokingly tweeted but have seriously
uh I'm not going to say exactly what I
said because it was graphic but I I
responded to Greg uh was it Greg price I
think I said said he said here's the guy
who did it I said is he the guy who's
getting or the guy giving and everyone's
like haha oh I'm like no this matters
because the dude the dude doing the deed
is wearing some kind of like head
mounted camera so you can't see his face
and the issue is if they've gotten
information through other means outside
of the video that the guy filming which
they said this guy filmed himself doing
it that's implying the guys whose face
you can't see is doing it and the guy
whose face you can't see is not him that
means there's another identifi
unidentified guy and I'm like the last
thing I'm going to do is call a guy out
on a show like this as having you know
enjoyed another man's company in a in a
public building unless I know for sure
that's the case but wait a second so
there's so there's a couple interesting
facts that you just laid out so this
person had a head-mounted camera deal I
think that's what it was on a
GoPro so I mean likely not the first
time this individual has done it maybe
in the building but don't you need you
have to have special pass to get access
to that part of the building too so it
had to be another staffer of somebody
well they could let them in a lot of
people on social media are saying that
this was the real Insurrection that has
happened I twe I tweeted
Insurrection Insurrection is trending I
think right now also well um it and
Schumer saying erection inside of the
erection is is trending as well I'm
guessing these are not the first two men
to um you know insert in the exit hole
in the in any of the
capital buildings but they might be the
first to film it probably not even at
least the first if you're filming it you
kind of want to get caught right no look
so I guess they were sharing it on
various websites like hah haa and it's
kind of
insane look guys can I just jump the
shark right now and say Civil War just
because because I'm like if we're at the
point where staffers of the Senate care
so little about this country they treat
our government buildings like like porn
sets I just don't see anyone having
enough confidence in this government to
maintain it I don't think that that
necessarily sexual debauchery is enough
to claim like you know conflict but
because I was actually talking to Ashley
Sinclair about yester she used to work
down there she's like it's just it's
just non-stop like debauchery I but you
know what I think that your
philosophical angle is right here Tim
what it what it shows is the lack of
respect the lack of concern the lack of
care the overall clown show that it
really is there's no reverence right I
mean it's the same thing with Jill
Biden's Christmas video there's no class
there's no reverence it's just a clown
show it's just let's just clown show
this up we don't care about the country
we don't respect the country we don't
rever the country we don't rever these
buildings I I mean I typically would
kind of stand where you are in and in
fact I I would say even after my prison
sentence I'm even more for prison reform
and Justice Reform empty the prisons at
this point uh but I understand where
you're going philosophically I wouldn't
be surprised though if with the
aftermath of this we don't start to see
more videos start to surface yeah um I I
have a different take I I kind of don't
care with these guys screwing each other
because the government screws us every
single day right uh you seriously you
look you look at the surveillance secret
FBI fisa bills that they just pass you
look at the ndaa you look at the funding
that they're probably going to be giving
Israel and Ukraine very soon as of
course the average American is being
fleeced and destroyed financially I
don't care what these two dudes did this
is not a place to be respected this is a
place has been hijacked by sociopathic
corporatist and globalists that are
using it as a machine to screw over
their American people and you're the one
getting familyfriendly show here um but
that stuff's been going on and the only
reason these two guys are willing to do
this is because they don't take our
government seriously why for everything
you for every reason you just explained
people are these guys are like oh this
government's a joke they rip people off
they blow kids up nobody takes it
seriously then they go off on theate
hearing Flor and they you just made a
meme you've just made a meme put the guy
who's facing away and you put the
American American taxer and then the
person doing
come my team my team you're watching get
on it get on it that's it though but
that really is making a t-shirt on the
best political shirts.com that a better
that is a much more offensive thing that
is a much more offensive thing oh you
don't want fisa oh you don't want
funding for Ukraine well we'll just go
ahead and slip it into the ndaa and
you're going to get it anyway I got to
be honest it's actually um the most
disgusting meme gift ever in that in a
government building Democrat staffers
did this cuz now you can put any group
you can put FBI on the guy and and J
Sixers on the other guy there's a reason
there's a sex position called the
taxpayer okay all right they were
utilizing it you've just hit the
infinity mem Stone seriously the shirt's
coming soon uh M infinity stone yeah you
could put Joe Biden on one guy and US
economy on the other guy oh
yeah on don't post that on my time
here we go it's everywhere here we go
please man cuz make sure you tweet this
in Eric July
now but you just set the woles I know
right to go out of their way I just set
myself up huh no no but on a serious
note no I think it's more so
representative of like the the
institution right like even when this
whole j6 uh thing happen you know I
don't pretend like the Congress isn't
like a band full of criminals and and I
get it you know we we people we have
this idealistic way of looking at
government and it's supposed to they're
sacred and uh their buildings are
something that is supposed to be
cherished and respected but I don't see
him that way you know I I haven't seen
him that way for a very long time but I
think this is more to your point
representative of the fact that it
absolutely is a clown show but I think
people seeing it that way and taking it
for what it actually is I don't
necessarily see that as a negative
negative thing I do believe that more
people should look at the senate or the
house and Congress just in general uh
with with more contempt when you really
truly understand the type of things it
is that they are absolutely doing so
they 100% are a band full of criminals
which is why I'm not I'm not at all
tripping off of off that just Qui good
thing that people will see this then
that that's the way that I see it I mean
if if if you look at it and you like and
you're like look this is a joke this is
a joke of an institution it is I would
agree with you it absolutely 100% is a
joke of an institution it's a it's a
place where people try to weaponize
things um and the and the power it is
that they have against their political
enemies it's not anything to be taken
seriously um like that at all so yeah
while you know to your point it's
probably all sorts of weird stuff that
does happen there dayto day that we
don't ever see it probably is a bunch of
debauchery and degeneracy um uh in there
anyway yeah hey he first point it was
that Eric D July correct got it second
point that clarify I just wanted to
clarify for the record second point I
wanted to make here this is nothing new
look at what they do at the Bohemian
Grove there's literal secret societies
there's literally a bro brich there's
literal like parties and secret things
that they do that we can't even mention
here on this friend familyfriendly
broadcast there's an island that they
bring children to so for me uh Hunter
Biden and this latest Revelation is the
least offensive thing that is happening
in Washington DC what's worth Jeffrey
tubin or these guys I mean tubin tubin
has the meme magic with his name already
in there but but I don't think you can
even compare you can what the Epstein
story way bigger of of a real issue that
that I think we should be outraged about
we should be showing videos of Bill
Clinton getting on the lito express we
should be showing uh Bill Gates and all
these other individuals connected going
to that private island that should be
the big controversy everyone in this
room is done more jail time than any of
Epstein's clients exactly wow that's
actually pretty crazy wait hold on hold
on uh Ian have you ever been in jail
negative oh okay all right well Eric
have
you obviously you were you were just
there I was kind of making the joke like
I was probably the only one but it would
still it would still equ to it long
longest I've been in jail was like was
like 14 hours or something uh Luke I
know for sure and then you know so I
think Ian's the only one here the
gruesomely straight edged character say
Joe Biden lost the 2020 election did he
just say it we'll put we'll get you're
ging me a free you're G me a free pass
you come I'm saying you can join us you
can join us on the other side it's a
right pass I it's a right pass Donald
Trump won in 2020 and they're going to
come get you I mean they they know where
you live Tim we know that me I I uh I I
just went because I was they locked me
up for skateboarding for like overnight
Luke I remember that where you were you
were in Europe or something there was
like eight times yeah seven excuse me
seven times it it was like like it was
all regarding my journalism I like grew
up really straight edge like follow the
rules follow order like my dad was in
the fire department what does have to do
with anything my dad was in the fire
department too and then like but later I
started to learn like the appreciation
of like if if evil laws are passed like
what the Nazis did you kind of like Jeff
Thomas Jefferson would say you kind of
have a right to like ignore those laws
or like if if if a government becomes
evil you're supposed to be like well
okay law isn't everything you actually
the Constitution if you read the
Constitution it says if if the lawmakers
get out of control you actually have a
duty to get them out of government it's
actually a duty in the Constitution if
our government comes corrupted that we
have to do something about it but but
Ian I I've never been convicted of
anything but I got arrested while I was
skateboarding they gave me some bogus
charge and then I spent half a day in
jail you've never had anything where
you're wow look at that so not even
detained back of a cop car oh yeah one
time my buddy had a joint in the car and
he was driving and the cops pulled us
over like a more than CLI a block away
from in he's in it but so they got we
got car we were only a block away from
as like where do you live I was like
right there and they're like okay get
out of here I was just sleeping in the
back seat okay let me to clarify the
extent of Ian's uh incarceration is a a
car and his a friend with his car a
friend who was driving a car he was in
was stopped briefly and he was let go
and that is more time served than any of
Epstein's clients the hypothetically
yeah literally there's no way to know
like some of those clients might have
been dirty dirty criminals and we
wouldn't know but for for being let's
say this it's more than any of them
served for the crime of being a client
of Epstein yes because that would be
zero as yeah exactly cuz maybe like one
of the clients beat a woman and got
arrested later on like I'm not saying
that you know what this story made me
think of when the two dudes getting it
on in the Senate is like uh the power
that one guy has to totally transform
the public conversation now like one guy
with a video camera can like bang
another guy and then everyone's talking
like 30 years ago you had to go through
NBC news like these videos couldn't even
get out anywhere unless someone at a
news organization was like well yes this
guy would go to NBC and say please air
this tape on your show they'd be like no
we're not doing and then they'd have to
have Polaroids they'd go or they maybe
they had a big handicam that wouldn't
fit on the guy head so they'd have to
have a third guy taking the video are
you saying that Joe Biden put him up to
this to get all the negative press about
Joe Biden out of the
media wow that's an interesting concept
like uh to to kind of be like hey what
Hunter is doing well there's other
people that also do this no it's not
just that I got to be honest I if if if
it came out I'm not saying that this is
true I'm saying if the news came out
that this guy was put up to it as I
believe it I'd be like oh wow like
they're like oh the Democratic
Administration knew a ton of press was
coming up Hunter Biden he divided
subpoena Joe Biden was defending him and
you know all these hookers $800 and
something thousand now I think the
number is in in prostitutes uh let's get
a guy out there a lot of hookers it's
crazy right one really lucky one no I
just saw the headline it was yeah or one
we know it's more than one hey
prostitutes are a big part of Washington
DC U there's a new York Post story
detailing how they're shipped into the
Bohemian Grove male prostitutes
specifically and there's also a very
famous story from the bush years where
George W bush got caught sneaking in a
gay porn star into the white house uh
that was another major Saga and Scandal
that kind of got swept under the rug so
this is this is this is now what we're
seeing finally happening but happens all
the time it's only outrageous because we
have video of it I think late stage
Empire Roman Empire they said part of a
late stage Empire is sexual Deery Tak
yep did this video break because of
Twitter or x i I think the Daily Caller
broke it the Daily Caller got the
exclusive but all of a sudden everyone's
X timeline is just FL that's where I saw
it on X can see the video it was not
censored when it came across my man I'm
like trying to avoid it I'm leaving
through it
man now it's over now it's over know man
it's I'm not even going to bother to try
to look at my timeline now because I
know it's going to be extrem but that's
why Twitter are actually so important
though not so you can watch this
debauchery but maybe if it this is the
kind of stuff they can censor and hide
for the people they want to protect y
but thank goodness Elon Musk is at least
allowing I would say 95% free speech on
his platform yeah I air on the side of
allowing it although it is it is it can
like wreck your brain to see it you
think it should have been censored or at
least blacked out in like a black box
like click here if you want to see it
pretty sure they'll do that I'm pretty
sure they're going to do that because it
just takes time for the AL to kick in
and then catch this stuff but my my my
position has been if if Elon Musk allows
13year olds in the platform then all
porn must be banned oh I agree porn
should not be on X it's everywh this
even newsworthy videos of like this
should not be allowed if there are young
it should be I mean YouTube does this
and and sometimes they get it wrong and
that sucks but I respect it they will
age lock a video and then people
complain being like why is my video
being age restricted oh it's not fair
and sometimes it's not fair but the
challenge is how do you allow people to
upload whatever they want while
preventing people from uploading things
that are illegal so what you so what
YouTube does with the age restriction
stuff is if someone posts this video of
these staffers on YouTube yeah it should
be age restricted now here's the problem
kids just lie they just sign up and
claim to be 18 we should not allow
people to to give these materials to
kids I'm sorry it's just like you
couldn't do it on TV I don't understand
how it became normal to be like you know
we were talking to um I think I was
talking to Steven Marsh the guy wrote
the Civil War book and he's like oh
these kids can get it on the internet so
who cares just let them get these books
in school anyway and I'm like they
should not get it on the internet either
yeah that's but but the mentality of
many liberals is because of the internet
we should just give kids these books and
I'm like no yeah I had a friend that
would be like if you're going to be late
dude who cares just be as late as you
you're already late just be an hour late
like that's not how it works dude if I'm
5 minutes late that's way less worse
than being an hour late it's same with
porn on the Internet like as little as
possible and I feel like that's like the
bottom of the hill argument like oh
they're going to find it anyway so let's
put it in the classroom like what oh
you're going to you're going to die
anyway so I'm just going to stab you now
it's just like it doesn't even make any
sense but don't you think I mean I think
I mean I do think Twitter should do
every cuz cuz YouTube I don't think you
can find any adult or pornographic
content on YouTube oh yeah you can it
get it's not that good either there's a
congressional there's a very similar
video to the Congressional video that
that's going viral right now on social
media that's up on YouTube that YouTube
is standing behind and argued that it is
what was it artistic work but it's uh
familyfriendly show here I thought that
was the twitch platform it was a dude
guessing what's being um H there's ways
around that yeah I would say how how do
I even describe this I don't want to get
with your eyes just look at the camera
and they'll know see I like that I think
that's a fair argument I forget who who
it might have even come across in a
courtroom is they were debating you know
what's pornography or what's like
artistic content and someone said when I
see it I know the judge said you know it
when you see it yeah and I think you
know it's a little open-ended but I
would say if if the same effort they put
into Twitter Banning conservatives or
Banning Alex Jones or myself or others
if they put that same effort into
stopping the pornographic content I
would I would think they could at least
limit it I had uh I on Wednesday I they
use AI now and I interviewed Dicky
Barrett the video got demonetized right
I was like we didn't even say because
his name was B guy I um oh really I went
to the monetization I was like well I
request a human review and they
immediately overturned it they were like
yeah it's fine it's but the word Dicky
caught the ai's attention cuz oh wow so
that's it's a little heavy-handed but
it's better than I guess no moderation
well so like the issue is when they use
it for political censorship not cool but
if someone's trying to put up videos of
these staffers you know doing a deed we
don't want kids finding that stuff so
there's got to be some way to deal with
this I'm sorry I don't know and there's
a lot of people the more Libertarians
don't like it they're like oh Tim's for
censorship and this is going to lead to
a whole bunch of problems I'm like bro I
don't I don't believe that because the
technology got invented we all of a
sudden throw out the rules where we're
like kids aren't allowed to be you can't
solicit adult materials to children like
you can't do it just because the
internet got invented doesn't mean you
can do it now you know so how do you
find the balance because when I was
watching when the video popped up on my
timeline I mean you can't really see
much I mean if you're an adult you know
what you're looking at and I obviously
wouldn't like that to be I would what my
kids see well see I must not have seen
the whole video I mean I didn't watch it
I I I saw it and I was like oh okay I
know what that looking around and like
oh really okay well I didn't go I didn't
go that deep into it no pun intended no
pun for for I did I watched it for the
people for the team so that I could
report back newsworthy though I mean
that's the thing like that is a news
story and you were doing I mean you're
doing you're doing show prep I gotta be
honest man like I've watched videos of
people being shot and murdered and
killed I watched a video of a guy
getting struck by lightning twice Phil
leonti posted that I've watched videos
of people being hit by trains like if
I'm going to try and understand what's
going on and there's a news story and
it's relevant I'm watching the video did
you watch on Twitter the video yeah I
think I watched it on The Daily Caller
okay cuz I'm saying how are you going to
watch that's tough because I feel like
maybe you kind of just let it go for a
little period of time just so people can
see it and you say okay we got to make
sure this doesn't go up because it is a
newsworthy story and I mean people
people want to know that this is what
your people in government are doing yeah
but I see what your point like if it
happens again tomorrow is that one
newsworthy too do we need to look at
that one as well and then the day after
are we supposed to look at that one too
like what are we looking at now people
are making tons of memes of this video
there we go oh yeah that's what I'm
talking about I think the answer that
what they're looking at is AI they're
going to use artificial intelligence to
to try and preempt it and and censor it
before it gets out but the problem with
that is like then are elbows too sexual
like where does the line get drawn is
with whoever's in power writing the code
of the AI is someone showing someone
neck skin is that too sexual cleavage
you know a round butt with pants on like
cankles yeah exactly how how
for I think one of the issues is when it
comes to this level of censorship the
issue is always if x is allowed then y
must be allowed to instead of if x is
allowed have we considered it should not
be for example uh they're do like right
now this is big thing where people will
like they'll print out male nipples
women will print out a picture of male
nipples and then stick them to their
nipples and then post a topless photo
and be like male nipp nipples are
alloted on Instagram but females aren't
so we're just showing male nipples and
you can't really tell them they're like
aha the argument they're making is well
then it should be allowed for all women
to go completely topless on social media
instead of being like okay dudes can't
dudes got to wear shirts too see but now
we're getting into this this this level
of we're just not behaving like adults
right I mean there needs to be some
level of an adult conversation here it's
like yeah we know what you're doing
that's funny you're not going to do it
not like oh I found the loophole give me
a break what do you guys think about the
free the nipple campaign
are you familiar with it is that when
the ladies run around naked basically
topless in New York City and because it
used to be the guys had to wear shirts
in public until like the 1920s guys got
to wear shirts they had to get the right
legally to be able to go topless in
public and now totally normalized
instead of saying women should be able
to be topless too how about we go the
see this what I'm talking about women
are saying men can wear not wear shirts
therefore women should be allowed to do
it as well how about we go we do the
inverse and say women aren't allowed to
wear shirt aren't allowed to be topless
then men shouldn't be allowed either why
not say no everybody got a wear shirt
nobody topl us anymore how come it
always goes in the One Direction of
closer and closer to
debauchery well I think it's obvious why
women can't walk around topless and men
can I mean yeah there'll be car
accidents yeah all the time that's what
I'm saying see this is like we're all
adults here I wouldn't be able to get
anything done we're all adults here we
know why women and you know the the
mamory gland is a little more
distracting than the uh the male
chesticles and so I don't think this is
just but it gets into petty stuff it's
like oh well if the man can do it then
why can't the woman you know why the
woman can't it's a it's a different body
it's a different body part it's a
different sexual arousal yeah we're more
than just brains humans are more than
just brains we can't just logic our way
through in in Most states it is legal
for women to be topless I mean I would
say as a as a as a very heterosexual man
the concept of women walking around
topless sounds great but then you see
these monsters you see these whales that
are engaging in the free the nipple
campaign uh shut it down so what happen
New York is yes I'm discriminating yes
there there are morbidly obese women who
do it and and police officers are like
ma'am you need to cover up and they go
no I don't and then when they get cited
or charged they'll menu the city and
instantly win really yeah they win of
course of course it is it it is it is
sex-based discrimination to say that
women can't be topless if a man can and
so my argument is no no no it's it's
real simple just tell the guys that got
to wear shirts too but also bikini
bottoms like those really really like G
string bathing suit bottoms like it
doesn't you don't Brazilian Brazilian
bikini it leaves nothing to the
imagination it's just like they're
basically walking around naked yeah but
because there's a piece of thread in the
butt it's even now they now they have
these like pieces of plastic that are
moldable that women just click like you
know what I mean there's not even straps
and it's just like okay we get the
future is going to be people put duct
tape on their junk and that's
it duct tape on it nudity is different
than sex that's for sure like nudity is
a very different thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a member
over at tim.com for uncensored
membersonly shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time